The third method we have
is something you are.
That's the biometric method.
So, what exactly is that?
So obviously,
there are a variety of biometrics and
it should be unique to you.
Somebody else shouldn't be able
to use a biometric feature or
set of features to impersonate you,
so what are some examples?
Fingerprints are one.
You swipe your finger for example, touch
ID and things like that and they look
for the pattern in your fingerprints and
based on that they say it's really you.
When it comes to keyboard if
nothing else, the way you type, or
the keystroke dynamics,
how fast you are, how long you take
from one key to the next depending on
what the keys are and things like that.
Sometimes that is used as
a biometric features derived from
this speed at which you type,
or pattern of your typing,
could be a biometric
that's unique to you.
Actually seeing devices that do
voice biometric authentication.
They extract a set of features from your
voice which hopefully is unique to you,
and that can be used when
you talk to the device,
it knows that it's really you.
And, of course, they're more intrusive
and fancier one like retina scan and
things like that, which look for
sort of unique patterns
based on the blood flow in your eye,
and things like that.
So these are basically what you are.
The way these work, is that you're
going to claim it's you and
you're going to swipe your finger,
or you talk in case of voice.
But the biometric measurement
should be the same each time.
If it's different then of course
we're going to have a false negative.
It's you but you're not able to
login because you have a cold and
your voice is a little different.
So maybe you don't have
exact of these measurements.
Maybe you have a probability
distribution for
your other features that we extract
from your biometric measurements.
And of course we're going to
have false positives and
false negatives, as we have with each
authentication method that we discussed.
Here, if your biometric measurements
change beyond a certain limit,
then of course you may
not be able to login.
Resulting in this false negative
that we were talking about.
So the basic way of implementing
biometric is there has to be
a biometric sensor, there's some user
interface where you swipe your finger or
camera takes a picture of you or
where you talk to it, or wherever it is.
That the interface, the sensor,
then from the biometric reading we're
going to extract a bunch of features
that actually describe the reading
that we just have from the sensor.
And that's passed to a biometric
database that stores these features, or
something that derives
from these features.
So PIN is here,
as sort of a separate thing we may have,
in addition too, PIN is something
you know, so that's the secret.
But say if you just sort
of going with biometric,
you would not have the top line here.
So the biometric database seems
like a hash values for passwords.
We have something that describes
the biometric feature set and
feature values for a given user.
So once you extract
the feature we compare those.
If there's a match between these two,
then we allow authentication.
If there isn't a match then we're
going to say that authentication
is not allowed.
So the idea is that you still
have the enrollment problem.
Somebody has to have a description
of your biometric features,
which is the database
where we'll be storing it.
The sensor has to read it, the features
have to be extracted, the comparison or
match has to happen.
And that's how biometric
authentication works.
So that when you're typing a password,
we sort of reading through the interface
and the sensor and then it's sort
of similar to what we had before.